[Aplausos]
o papa será aqui estão ouvindo tudo
certo
é bom
antes de começar qualquer coisa eu
gostaria de fazer uma pergunta pra vocês
com a fisionomia de um físico
angelina jolie por exemplo era uma
física ou então o brad pitt o brad pitt
um físico ou então na verdade o físico é
um cara que usa óculos num cabelo
cacheado cidade carioca faz internet vez
em quando é bom não tenho dúvida de que
qualquer um aqui escolheria de fato a
terceira opção e agora eu tenho uma
outra pergunta pra vocês
o que vocês acham que é física a física
é um conjunto de letrinhas gregas que
você não entende muito bem o que
significam e que o seu professor
continua insistindo pra você dizendo que
eles querem dizer alguma coisa no mundo
real ou a física é um conjunto ainda
maior destas letrinhas que você continua
sem saber muito bem o que quer dizer mas
que o seu professor continua dizendo que
quer dizer alguma coisa ou na verdade é
física é a união dessas duas coisas você
tem esse conjunto de letrinhas você dá
uma interpretação para isso no mundo
real e você pode por exemplo prever o
futuro e dizer por exemplo um qual
velocidade uma barrinha está rodando
dentro de um recipiente por exemplo ou
várias outras aplicações
hoje eu vou explicar para vocês um pouco
de como cheguei a essa conclusão de que
tudo isso é física
tudo começou em 2013 quando eu descobri
uma competição chamada ypt que o inter
na china yang fez stones ou em português
o torneio internacional dos físicos é
diferente de qualquer outra competição
de física que você simplesmente escreve
as respostas entrega por seu professor
pra ele corrigir essa competição instiga
você aí para o laboratório a trabalhar
em 17 problemas abertos em física de
maneira experimental e depois quando
você fez todos os experimentos variou
tudo
você podia variar você vai lá e
consultas letrinhas gregas e diz se de
fato você tá conseguindo prever o futuro
da maneira certa o que você poderia
mudar nisso
são problemas muito interessantes como
por exemplo o porquê que você consegue
reacender uma vela depois que ela se
apagou
ou então o porquê quando você joga tinta
na água a tinta parece que começa a se
dissolver e se divide em vários a
nezinho diferentes e você pode até
talvez contar o número desses marquinhos
e saber por exemplo daqui a dez segundos
quando os arquivos vão se formar
ou então mais interessante ainda como
você consegue fazer uma aurora boreal
dentro do laboratório a menor aurora
boreal possível bom foi baseado nessas
perguntas fascinantes que eu participei
do y pt em 2013
e eu tenho a dizer pra vocês que desde a
primeira vez que eu subi naquele palco
para explicar um pouco sobre física eu
tinha descoberto na verdade uma grande
paixão que me acompanha até hoje
depois que a gente participou dessa
primeira vez a gente claro decidiu que
queria participar novamente do torneio
e aí no ano seguinte a gente reuniu um
grupo de pessoas com até um professor
que não era da nossa escola que estava
interessado em ajudar e se reunir
esporadicamente mas um dia nessas
reuniões aconteceu uma coisa que quase
estragou tudo que eu tenho pra contar
hoje enquanto ele estava numa dessas
reuniões explicando um pouco passando
falando sobre física sobre a competição
eu olhei assim pra porta e viu a
professora passando e eu sabia que essa
professora ela não gostava muito do que
a gente estava fazendo lá no y pt
essa professora então subiu as escadas
foi na coordenadora da escola e disse
para ela que estava fazendo coisas
terríveis lá com o professor de outra
escola que indevida lá ela desceu da
sala dela bateu na porta
e me chamou e perguntou mateus quem é
esse professor está aí com você eu
expliquei que ele era de outra escola
que ele estava lá para ajudar gente que
tinha autorização para estar lá e ela
virou pra mim e disse matheus
essa escola não é a sua casa para você
trazer quem você quiser aqui e quando
você é uma criança e houve esse tipo de
coisa é algo terrível e eu me sentia
assim completamente desamparada nessa
hora e durante a semana que passou eu
pensei realmente que eu não devia estar
lá fazendo experimentos que eu não devia
estar estudando física e eu realmente
tinha desistido do y pt mas na semana
seguinte a diretora da escola me chamou
e disse que confiava no que a gente
estava querendo trazer pra escola que
ela queria que a gente participasse de
algum jeito
e aí tudo bem nós
repensei e foi bom essa é a primeira vez
que as coisas deram errado vão então
vamos seguir em frente e aí a gente
procurou algumas pessoas para participar
na internet mesmo pessoas e até outros
estados quiseram participar como por
exemplo de minas gerais da bahia ea
gente formou uma equipe e as coisas
estavam indo muito bem
a gente tava até sonhando em chegar
talvez a etapa internacional da
competição que era a coisa que a gente
mais queria mas algumas semanas antes do
torneio uma dessas pessoas que a gente
tinha chamado disse que não podia mais
participar porque tinha mudado de escola
enfim não queria participar da
competição
mas pouco tempo depois descobri que na
verdade é essa pessoa que estava com a
gente tinha ido para uma outra escola e
formado uma outra equipe
mesmo com todas as pesquisas que a gente
tinha feito durante todos aqueles meses
e foi nesse momento que de fato eu
pensei que era o momento de desistir que
era o momento de não participar do y pt
deixar os experimentos para lá
mas os meus amigos disseram poxa mateus
mas a gente já passou por tudo isso não
tem porque a gente existe agora e aí
confiando neles nós fomos lá e
participam pela primeira vez no torneio
é não pela primeira vez a gente
participou na edição de 2014
vocês podem ver até a minha enorme
alegria ali em vermelho participar neste
torneio porque além de tudo a gente
acabou sendo cabeça de chave da
competição e depois até ganhou medalha
de bronze então era uma conquista muito
grande pra gente estava muito feliz de
estar lá pra mim esse era o momento mais
alto da minha vida né
como o físico com o cientista estudantes
como pessoa e aí as coisas
o tempo passou a gente saiu do ensino
médio eu entrei na universidade e não é
que o bc quando você tem tanto a
interdisciplinaridade assim às vezes
isso pode atrapalhar e eu me sentia
assim completamente perdido no começo
porque eu não consegui achar uma coisa
que me dessem tanta paixão quanto o iptm
dava quando era criança e foi nesse
momento que eu estava sim prestes a
desistir de tudo também que eu lembrei
de uma competição que se chamava e pt
que não é internet no young fez esses
homens na internet não fez história do
torneio nacional dos físicos em que
estudantes de universidades do mundo
inteiro apresenta as suas soluções da
mesma maneira como no y pt
e aí eu conversei com o professor
professor antônio que até hoje é o meu
orientador e ele disse que a gente devia
participar dessa competição ea gente
devia procurar participantes pra ir em
representar o brasil e depois de todas
as dificuldades mesmo passando por tudo
que a gente tinha passado para arranjar
dinheiro pra pagar passagem ou taxa de
inscrição
nós conseguimos estar lá então em 2017
representando o brasil no que foi a
primeira equipe brasileira
a história do pt até então e quando a
gente chegou lá a gente se perguntou
ainda mas será que é possível chegar
mais longe que pra mim por exemplo já
era o meu próprio sonho já não sendo
realizado vai para uma competição
internacional
mas será que a gente conseguir chegar
mais longe do que isso a gente voltou
para o brasil e chegou à conclusão de
que sim era possível e nós decidimos
então trabalhar muito duro para chegar
no iptu do ano seguinte
nós abrimos mão de muitas coisas das
nossas iniciações científicos dos novos
mestrados das nossas próprias gravações
para nos dedicarmos bastante porém pt à
porta do aeroporto se abriu ea gente
sentiu um frio de menos três graus de
fato agora já estava na rússia
e quando a gente olhou para o céu tinha
neve caindo como nenhum de nós jamais
ter visto cair e foi nesse ambiente
nesse frio nessa toda essa pressão que
nos primeiros rounds do torneio
a gente conquistou vários pontos assim
que levaram a gente até a semi final
desse torneio vai ser um problema para
chegar na final
a gente tem que passar pela semifinal e
na semifinal a gente só tinha um
problema que a gente podia fazer para
apresentar um entre oito possíveis de um
dia para o outro então a gente fez a
apresentação desse problema
e foi exatamente esse problema que a
equipe da rússia pediu pra gente que era
a solução de como funcionava um buraco
negro supersônico
e foi graças a esse problema que a gente
chegou então a terceira colocação do
campeonato mundial dos físicos
esse é o momento mais alto da minha vida
como físico com o estudante cientista
mas a gente não se perguntou será que o
pt é só isso é só uma competição que
você vai lá ganhou o prêmio e pronto
acabou ea gente chegou à conclusão
também de que não que o pt tinha que
continuar de algum jeito
foi assim que nasceu o projeto de
extensão como a física pode mudar o
mundo em que a gente visitava escolas
para falar para aquelas crianças que a
física não era só aquelas letrinhas que
a gente escrevia e que ninguém sabia o
que significava mas que na verdade é
física está no nosso dia-a-dia a física
explica por que por exemplo você olha
para o céu e o céu é azul porque eu
consigo enxergar melhor com os óculos
porque vocês estão enxergando aqui agora
porque é desse jeito que a gente ia
conseguir mudar o mundo usando a física
outro momento marcante nessa trajetória
foi quando a gente participou da
seletiva nacional porque veja depois que
a gente chegou em terceiro lugar
muitas equipes do brasil também ficaram
interessadas em participar etc ea gente
no dia da competição eu me lembro sim
claramente quando a gente entrou na sala
e eu vi outra equipe de outra escola da
da usp e eu vi todos os jurados também
discutindo sobre física discutindo sobre
aqueles problemas que eram basicamente
os mesmos problemas que cinco anos antes
só eu acreditava quando eu estava na
minha escola
existe uma frase que ela explica muito
bem
tudo que a gente viveu durante esse
tempo que é mais ou menos assim existem
dois tipos de pessoas no mundo um tipo
de pessoa que vê um grande desafio um
desafio enorme
mas se sente incapaz e decide não tentar
de uma maneira trabalhar para fazer com
que as respostas chegam mais perto para
esse problema existe um outro tipo de
pessoa que embora seja impossível chegar
à resposta não dorme até conseguir
chegar um pouquinho mais perto da
resposta desse grande problema
quem disse isso foi uma pessoa célebre
foi justamente a professora cíntia chang
que me convidou para fazer pesquisa com
ela no canadá e não por causa das minhas
notas porque como eu disse
a gente abre mão de muita coisa para
participar disso tudo
e foi justamente por causa disso porque
as pessoas disseram que a gente não
devia estar lá ea gente não podia
participar do torneio que a gente devia
estudar outras coisas dedicar só na
escola só na universidade mas a gente
estava lá ea gente mostrou que
conseguiria fazer isso eu sou mateus
pessoa e eu sou o cientista não porque
eu escolhi recentes mas por que a vida
me mostrou isso e se você está
assistindo isso está com alguma dúvida
então aqui vai uma grande verdade a
verdade é que todos nós somos cientistas
encontre o cientista que há dentro de
você
obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]